(uplifting music)
- When I tell people that I'm a wrestler
they don't really believe me at first.
I don't know what image
they have in their head
of what a wrestler should look like.
Especially when I say
I'm the super heavyweight
for women's wrestling.
And they're like, "You wrestle,
you're kind of too pretty to wrestle".
It's always interesting
to me, 'cause I'm like,
"What did you expect?"
(upbeat music)
My name's Adeline Gray, I'm
a three-time world champion.
Ranked number one in the world,
been undefeated for two and a half years.
And I'm gonna compete in the
Rio Olympic Games in August.
I never really considered the
Olympics as an option for me
when I was a younger kid and
it's something that I don't
think enough girls have an
opportunity to dream about.
(upbeat music)
I want to redefine feminine to some extent
and to have people challenge the way
they look at the word strong
and not just see a boy
that pops into your head.
I started wrestling boys
when I was six years old
and I wrestled boys all the
way through high school.
(upbeat music)
And I think I earned a lot
of respect from a lot of
the teammates out there who
did lose to me or maybe beat me
and I got to train with
the best guys in the world
and they made me tougher.
They made me work for every single point
I had to wrestle with and
they made it so that I could
be a champion on the women's level now.
We teach girls to be perfect
and boys to take risks.
I need to take risks, that
I am a confident and strong
female who knows that
I'm great at wrestling.
And I'm still struggling
with that concept that
I'm worried about not being
perfect when I step on the mat.
(soft piano music)
I have to step on that mat
and make sure that I work
every single moment to
win an Olympic gold medal.
I want young girls to be
able to look at that, my situation
and be able to dream about it.
I'm excited for that moment
to have my flag risen
and be able to know that I'm gonna
hold a gold medal around my neck.
(soft piano music)